okay so the brand new batman trailer is
absolutely incredible i don't think i'm
overselling it when i say this looks
like it might be the best batman movie
ever and the new teaser is filled with
easter eggs hidden details and a lot of
things that hint towards what's going to
be happening in the movie we start off
with the batmobile racing after the
penguin in a chase that has been seen
throughout several of the trailers i
believe that this takes place
immediately after batman invades his
club which may or may not be the iceberg
lounge we know from interviews with
colin farrell that he's not going to be
in the movie that much so i'm guessing
that this is all tied in together later
on we see a moment where both bruce and
selena are intercut inside a club and
from the looks of which he's in disguise
whilst he's falling behind to see what's
going on in these clips selena is
wearing a red wig which we'll talk about
later on but she's clearly trying to get
to the penguin as much as he is bruce's
black circles around his eyes which we
know he's gonna also have under the mask
so this may happen before he suits up
and then tries to take the penguin down
now we do get a shot in which we can
catch him in this disguise out in the
rain from behind this is somewhat a nod
to batman yeah one in which the
character went downtown in order to
fight crime on a low level basis he
ended up coming face to face with a pimp
and he also punched selena kyle in the
face so how's that for equality now this
was actually classed as their first
meeting and it is possible that this
could also happen at this point i
absolutely love the way these little
elements all tied together and it makes
for such a good opening
i'm sorry now this chase scene is
interrupted by mayoral candidate bella
real who says bruce wayne actually got a
lot of flashes of the opening of the
dark knight returns here as that
similarly opens with a race in which his
name is set at several points in the
same manner in that book we watched as
an older bruce wayne who'd retired from
being batman struggled with living a
normal boring life and i love how from
the editing here that we get the idea
bruce's mind is somewhere else bella
real doesn't actually pull from the
comics and she's someone who's
completely brand new for this film at
one point in the new look we can
actually catch one of her billboards in
which she promises change for gotham if
you cast your mind back to the first
trailer then you might remember that the
shot in which bruce was in the cave also
had one of her adverts playing on a
screen and it's clear that she could
bring something new to the crime-ridden
city she also says that his staff have
been screening her calls and gives him
the old you know the one the one that's
always on twitter where people say why
can't you just give money to the police
bruce no one's no one's ever thought of
this one before now one thing people
don't tend to take into account is that
corruption is rife within gotham so it
would pretty much be like signing up to
heavy spoilers patreon even though you
know he's just gonna spend it all on
funko pops during this conversation we
get into cuts of the chase and at one
point can see signs saying gotham docks
which we know from the first trailer is
a location that penguin has a gunfight
at my guess is that he carries out all
his shady business there and the reason
this chase happens on a freeway to it is
because penguin was retreating there as
it's where a lot of his men are you also
catch a sign that says robinson island
which may be a nod to robinson park a
landmark in gotham city that poison ivy
often lives at bella brings up bruce's
family and how they were philanthropists
but i think this movie makes it pretty
clear that they're actually not all they
were cracked up to be how am i part of
this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruce
wayne
this was a motif that i remember being
talked about in the batman telltale
games and we learned throughout them
that the wanes were actually just as bad
as the rest of the elite in the city
instead of wanting to improve gotham
they'd pretty much milk the city more
than i was milking squid game videos
when it was popular and they're one of
the main factors as to why everything is
so bad the riddler hidden set this at
several points in the teaser and it's
clear that he has a vendetta against
bruce and also the waynes i love that
the idealism of them is being questioned
and it was of course also explored in
joker when we saw what they were like
through the eyes of those that had lost
out whilst they'd grown more and more
wealthy i have a feeling that there's
more to bellary allen meets the eye and
the fan theories about her being talia
al ghul could be correct battle royale
is such a weird name and if you look at
the origins of bella it means beautiful
and real means well real say best easter
eggs on the internet now beautiful real
is something that people use to describe
my channel but it's also a bit of a
weird name i'd love to see if it turned
out that this was talia and that the
league of shadows were actually
attempting to infiltrate gotham through
planning their number one daughter as
the mayor of the city she gives a great
introduction and speaking of
introductions if this is your first time
here then welcome to the heavy spoilers
show we do videos like this every day so
if you're enjoying it then please hit
that thumbs up button and also make sure
you subscribe you absolute sucker you'll
love it yeah i promise you you'll have a
laugh now from here we get continued
shots of the car chase including how
batman sends penguin's car flying
we know from the second trailer that the
chase ends with batman walking towards
the car looking like a bat out of hell
and i do find it funny that the two
biggest comic book movies this decade
have been heavily promoted using bridge
scenes what do you mean it's a freeway
not a bridge what you mean it's not even
a freeway and i'm using american terms
incorrectly get the hell out of here now
we then get gordon saying that the
riddler is calling for batman and we
learn in this trailer that he's figured
out that bruce wayne is the dark knight
this is something that comes from the
comics most notably hush in which he
helped to terrorize bruce's life with
his childhood friend tommy elliott
riddler figured out quite quickly that
bruce was batman but he also realized
that a riddle everyone knew the answer
to meant it had no power thus he never
told anyone and it's clear that this
version has an either though he is
taunting the character we find in his
hideout that he's left behind a map on
the floor which has the words a real
change written in the middle of it this
is of course playing upon belarus slogan
and how he doesn't believe that she will
actually change anything it's rumored
that in the movie he will be killing
high ranking officials in gotham such as
the mayor and that his office is where
the first trailer opens when we get the
reverse shot of this map scene we can
also see what appears to be a poster for
the mayor but alongside this is one for
thomas wayne though it's difficult to
make out this image says wayne for
murderer potentially showing that in
this universe he also ran for mayor this
calls back to not only joker but it was
also a feature of batmania 1 which this
movie is also going to be heavily based
upon we can also catch an image of bruce
just below this showing how the movie
could be about the sun inheriting the
sins of the father this is a line that
actually pops up later in the trailer
and it's clear that everything is just
getting pinned on bruce now in the room
we can catch what appears to be the
color explosive that comes into things
later on showing that this is where the
riddler creates all of his traps we then
get alfred asking why riddler is writing
to batman clearly referencing the clues
that have been left behind beyond that
though there's also a phone that we see
pop up throughout the trailer that the
pair used to facetime each other
imagine there's no heaven
well what the hell was that anyway
riller says that he's been trying to
reach him and here we can also catch a
chair in the background against his
symbol on the back wall this symbol
appears throughout the trailer at
several times including a point in which
batman shines a uv light on one the
symbol and the design of the riddler
have purposely been depicted like this
in order to mimic the real-life zodiac
killer the zodiac sent encrypted
messages to the press and it's only
recently that his identity was figured
out after one of these was hacked on the
opposite side
is hacked the right terminology i don't
know but on the opposite side of this
phone call we can see what appears to be
a wig so this could be selena in her
getup from earlier i'm not sure if
that's right but make sure you leave a
comment below to let me know who you
think this is now interestingly it looks
like the riddler is going to be doing a
lot of these facetime messages
throughout the film as we can see that
d.a coulson also has one later on as
part of his trap this scene is actually
influenced by a collar bomb bank heist
that was carried out in real life and
it's the subject of a documentary on
netflix called evil genius it's really
messed up and i definitely recommend
that you check it out as it's probably
gonna have a lot of things in it that
this film touches upon in some way or
another
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
now colson at one point can also be seen
speaking into a phone whilst the riddler
is on the other side of it so this motif
will clearly pop up time and time again
also am i the only one who hates face
timing people just have to stop what
you're doing to talk to someone you have
to get ready and stuff and just send a
text next time riddler just send a
[ __ ] text now golson's name also
appears in the clues that bruce maps out
later on along with no more lies which
is something that can be seen on the
tape covering his mouth as well as the
one completely over the mayor's head the
scene in which coulson is held hostage
is meant to happen during the mayor's
funeral which is also where bruce meets
bella real over the top of this selena
says the riddler's latest is all about
the wanes and that if they don't stand
up no one will
look there's latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strength this is taking place inside her
apartment which is full of cats this
could actually be a reference to one of
their first meetings in the comics in
which bruce was badly injured and selena
nursed him back to help she didn't
remove his mask and it could also
explain how he ends up here and the
reason why she doesn't know that he's a
wayne she says she has a thing about
strays and we then see the pair fighting
in the mayor's office it is believed
that she's going to be breaking into
this to steal a ledger which is what she
does in the opening of the long
halloween this was at carmine falcone's
penthouse who was revealed to be her
father and it is thought that the two
will be related in this movie as well
this also leads into the bike chase that
we saw the behind the scenes of earlier
in the air which people were falling
over themselves to be a part of chabao
now bruce has clearly been keeping a
close eye on selena and as alfred
remarks that he has a new friend we can
see an image of her behind him once more
wearing that wig cut to a full shot of
the riddler at the location that i
believe is where the final fight will
take place it seems like lots of people
will be in his forces causing an
uprising against gotham and this is
likely where the bella real billboard is
along with the final fight we see which
looks absolutely amazing looks like
bloody arkham doesn't it looks so good
sign is up now now riddler is here
holding a rifle and this could be used
to give a note to the dark knight
returns in which batman also had one but
it could just be a reach now this might
not even be the actual riddler as later
on in the trailer we do see two in what
appears to be the same position and both
are dressed very similarly we then see a
shot of the center of gotham which is
deliberately done up to look like a
sleazy times square on the buildings we
can catch one that says gotham empire
and you just get the feeling from this
that the place isn't very nice now as
the ruler describes this as a cesspool
of a city we see bruce driving along to
what i believe will be the mayor's
funeral here we can catch a citizen
holding up a riddler symbol showing how
the villain has inspired the lower class
people to rise up next we catch batman
standing over the city at night and to
the right of him we can also see the bat
signal this is accompanied by shots of
the riddler getting arrested at the
coffee shop and let's just take a second
to appreciate how good this film looks
the cinematography is absolutely
incredible and every single frame looks
like it could be a painting at one point
we see the riddler's question more
coffee and he also says that he knows
bruce wayne is batman now from here we
get doors opening with bruce standing in
the middle of a circle showing that he
is somewhat a target now cut to a shot
in which he gets shot a lot and also
gordon and bruce investigating a dark
and dingy environment this is where we
see a door that says where it all began
in riddler green and above it there's a
sign that i can't quite make out but if
you can comment comment comment now
there are rumors that the riddler or
rather edward nashton will have been an
orphan much like bruce and that he will
have grown up in an orphanage which this
location could be there are rumors going
around that this will tie in with the
renewal project but that it'll turn out
the kids here were actually exploited by
the wanes and that this was actually
just a front clearly alfred knew
something about this as bruce says you
lied to me alfred now alfred replies by
saying that we all have our scars which
is tied in nicely with us getting a
glimpse at the scars on bruce's back
this is actually referencing a famous
piece of art by alex ross in which bruce
could be seen shirtless with all his
scars on display he says you're still a
wayne which is when we see one of the
family's personal cufflinks which is an
item that appears throughout the trailer
this movie is really gonna question what
it means to have wealth if you only use
it to help yourself and bruce will not
only be discovering what the waynes did
but also redefining what it means to be
one go to commissioner pete savage
saying that batman is involved in this
to gordon gordon denies this but savage
rightly asks how he knows
oh he's not
involved delany
and my favorite batman stories have
always been ones where he's very close
to being on the other side of the law
himself and i love this idea that he's
going to be a suspect too we then see
him being chased by the police and can
actually catch his grappling hook coming
out of his gauntlet before he fires it
upwards i love this shot as it shows
that he's planned a quick exit if he
ever needs one and we watch him
traveling up a staircase whilst the
police fire at him this appears to tie
into the glider chase that happens later
on and i love how batman is just so
above the police that they can't catch
him even when they throw everyone they
have at him over the top of this we hear
bruce telling selena not to throw her
life away to which he says don't worry i
got nine of them selena they'll throw
your life away
don't worry honey i get nine of them
behind her appears to be a riddle
hostage and as she jumps off the
building later in this scene we can see
what appears to be gordon attempting to
pull batman off him i think that batman
might be beating him up and potentially
this guy could have dressed as the
riddler and been carrying out attacks
next we see the riddler's reign of
terror over the city which includes
explosives going off this actually also
pulls from earth 1 in which the riddler
was a terrorist that detonated bombs
throughout the city in order to cause
the most damage possible we can see that
the riddler is actually flooding the
city which is such a good way to watch
the destruction happening as opposed to
what normally happens which is usually
just splosions now the drawing from
earlier shows that he's mapped out the
entirety of gotham and it shows he's
well aware of the layout and that he
knows how to strike at its weakest
points batman also answers the riddler's
riddle and selena calls him vengeance
which closes out the trailer come on
vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
now on the final screen you might notice
there's a weird code on the bottom which
when deciphered brings up this website
can't pronounce it so i'm just putting
it on screen but if you click it it has
a very interesting result so far no one
has figured out everything that's going
on with it but it does take you to this
site that seems like a command prompt
that will reveal things about the movie
the more that people dive into it i wish
the hackers were here or that i had an
iq above 50 as i'd be able to get them
easter eggs so i need you guys to do it
so that i can make money off all your
hard work get them easter eggs you punk
now as for my thoughts in the trailer
boom mind blown so so good and i'm
absolutely blown away by how incredible
the film looks my hype is through the
roof right now and i think this teaser
will completely shut the naysayers up at
this point as i don't even know how you
can hate anymore this is not only one of
the best comic book movies i've ever
seen cinematography wise but the
atmosphere in general feel is just so
menacing this is such a well put
together trailer and how all the shots
kind of tie in together to fit the
narrative and it works on a number of
levels i'm just so hyped for this and
the score action look of the film
costume design and everything is ticking
all of the boxes for me
[ __ ] i might even go back and watch the
twilight movies because i'm blown away
by robert pattinson's performance
honestly i think if this blows up that
dc should maybe move away from trying to
copy the mcu and just lean into what
they're good at which is these dark and
gritty portrayals considering this movie
costs 100 million dollars and that's
normally half the price of most comic
book films it looks incredible and shows
what a skill director can do when given
the right material honesty just looks
amazing i haven't got anything bad to
say about it and this is my most
anticipated movie of 2022 now i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on it
so make sure you comment below and let
me know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of the spider-man 4k trilogies on the
3rd of december and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown for the trailer of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over all the easter eggs we
could find in it talked about some of
the leaks and just gave a general
reaction so definitely head over there
right after this if not then thanks for
sitting through the video hope you had a
good christmas hope you have an even
better new year i'll see you on the next
one you take care of yourself peace